[Music]
this is fantastic that rodeo comes back
to vegas i mean
honestly for the past three decades this
is the home of the national finals rodeo
and we can't wait for it to be back here
in december after moving to texas
in 2020 the cowboys and the bucking
bulls are planning a comeback in las
vegas this winter
thanks for joining us here at 11 o'clock
i'm denise feltes and i'm brian loftis
with all that excitement surrounding nfr
vegas has a lot to look forward to this
year
madison kimbrough is live from fremont
street with what people can expect as
major events plan a return to our city
madison
yes it's true there is so much going on
and we are just getting started take a
look here here on fremont street
where we spoke to visitors and locals on
the strip as well who are excited
about this vegas revival now just coming
back and seeing this it's amazing
it's fun from new resorts to residencies
football welcoming back fans and now
with the announcement of the rodeo
coming back to town
vegas has so much to look forward to as
we look ahead to the next coming months
of 2021
it's going to be exciting because people
are just bored sitting home
usher bruno mars leading the list of
artists who plan to perform this summer
with celine dion and carrie underwood
among several other artists who are also
set to have residencies
at the brand new resorts world opening
in june visitors and locals weigh in on
their thoughts about it all more money
will come back to the area you know
that's the biggest thing that's missing
right now
getting the restaurants back opened up
and all the things that have to have
closed just for
short term you know just getting it back
on his feet i guess
i think that the first couple of weeks
will be kind of overwhelming i think it
will be
something to look forward to but at the
same time take safety precautions
raider nation will also return in a big
way with fans allowed to watch
inside allegiant stadium so with all of
this to look forward to
many say they trust las vegas to make
the right decision in opening venues up
i'd imagine it'd be exciting for
the locals because they're probably used
to a lot of people and
just a lot just seeing a lot of people
from all over
the world i'd imagine
we also can't forget life is beautiful
and edc
two massive music festivals returning
this fall so it all
is shaping up to be a very very strong
comeback for
our town for our city las vegas
reporting from fremont street madison
kimbrough
8 news now matt